three leaders in step the pm with his
dutch and canadian counterparts at raf
northhold hi guys
this a show of solidarity and strength
as we enter the twelfth day of war
troops on standby to assist you may have
to be calling on your services
a lot more
a thousand british soldiers already
committed to providing humanitarian aid
and more may follow when it comes to
this crisis there's no end in sight
old allies and friends are more
appreciated than ever
[Music]
and with many things to discuss as the
west grapples with its response to war
in europe putin is doubling down on his
aggression
and he is
deciding to attack in a pretty
indiscriminate way that's producing
huge waves of people we're going to have
to respond to that and we will
over 1.5 million refugees already how to
help ukraine and put paid to putin's
mission the agenda for these men prime
ministers will putin fail will putin
fail sars
leaders determined to make sure he does
the world is clearly changing and i
think that what we can't do uh post uh
the invasion of ukraine is assume that
we can go back to a kind of status quo
ante a kind of new normalization in the
way that we did after the invasion of
crimea
russia a pariah state that must be
isolated financial sanctions in place
attention now on banning russian oil
imports it's too bad that we are so
dependent on russian oil but we're not
going to make that mistake again
and in the meantime this war only
worsens
can you de-escalate or do you accept
that you just have to let this play out
and it's going to get a lot worse and
it's going to take a long long time at
this moment it is very difficult to
de-escalate at the same time i'm happy
that
both schultz but also macron are still
trying to get into contact with putin
the prime minister with the canadian and
dutch leaders today all of them put in
on a united front and insisting that the
west will eventually defeat putin
through economic if not direct military
might but there are questions too about
whether the prime minister's rhetoric
matches reality with criticism in his
own backyard over the slow sanctioning
of russian oligarchs and whether or not
the uk is taking enough ukrainian
refugees
tonight have promised to ramp up
processing across europe but just 300
visas now issued against 18 000
applications in a matter of days mps on
both sides are not convinced we're doing
enough in 1972
we took into kent thousands of uganda
nations
we did it almost overnight without any
difficulty at all
last monday my right honourable friend
told me that she would cut away the red
tape why aren't we doing it people who
are being told to wait 72 hours after
their security checks are all cleared
just because of bureaucracy
these not the last world leaders the pm
will meet this week as he looks to play
a leading role in the western front
against putin but he'll be judged on the
home front too when it comes to his
handling of rich russian oligarchs and
refugees beth rigby sky news westminster
[Music]